part of the whole argument against
digital is that some formats change over
time and we lose the the key to unlock
those formats I'll tell you why that's
ridiculous later but language and
permanence is an even worse problem so
this is why I think proprietary format
is overblown this is Luke chapter 2
verse 8 I I can't read these oh you're
not seen it yet I'm sorry I'm looking at
the wrong screen ok Luke chapter 2 verse
8 if anybody know Old English I'm sure
cameo does yeah you can read this can
you can you read the first line for us
yes I'll get that that's impressive give
a round of applause so and unless and
unless we keep him alive we're
so that's Old English in the middle we
have Middle English which I I only know
what this means because I I kind of know
what the last one means which is
Shakespearean that's let's look at the
years of this this is six hundred Common
Era not long ago
let's go five hundred years ahead and we
got middle English 1100 Common Era and
then Shakespearean you know the
Shakespeare's age which anybody who's
been through college will tell you that
that stuff's not easy to read either and
it's only 500 years old so every every
five hundred years I mean these are
really tough iterations and we're
talking ten thousand years so we've got
twenty iterations of this this is a
really bad game at Chinese whispers and
it looks like Chinese to me by the time
you go through this so we'll talk about
why proprietary format is overblown but
how do we deal with this in 10,000 years
no one can read any of these and this is
only gonna I think accelerate as
languages start talking to each other
and as vernacular starts exploding with
technology all the popular culture
references in here will just be
gibberish like anyone who reads
Shakespeare and it's trying to get the
the contemporary jokes so that's a huge
problem
[Music]